record numbers of migrants at the border
as Alex mentioned with CBP sources
predicting another record number in
December meanwhile customs and boorder
protection now say that over 240,000
people were apprehended at the border
last month setting a record for the
highest November on record for more on
this let's bring in former acting ice
director Tom homman and the Fox News
contributor Tom I want to get right to
the numbers we're getting and we got the
de November numbers the December numbers
are on track to even break all records
we might even see a
300,000 month what what do you make of
the situation right now because what all
of my border patrol sources are telling
me literally all of them is that this is
truly a Breaking Point the likes of
which we've never
seen well look I think you're right I
think December when those numbers come
in it'll be the highest month in history
of any month of any year and the bitol
is going to be 100 years old in in
another four months and look the borol
is broke I mean I was down in Texas on
border with Texas DPS two weeks ago I
talked to many bitol agents they're
broke I mean their Spirits are broke I
mean these these men and women are are
Beyond you know any hope of any help
from this Administration they feel like
they've been abandoned by the president
they've been abandoned by the Secretary
of Homeland Security they're they're
processing uh illegal aliens 24/7 that's
all they're doing and they're in such a
hurry to process I talked to crew agent
said they're not looking through pocket
trash anymore for information
intelligence information about the
organization that smuggling who they're
paying where they're going they're not
even able to do a deep dive into their
identification as you know grip you've
been on there many times they throw
their identifications away South of the
Border they get here and usually it it
involves an investigative interview to
find out who these people really are and
they can't even do that anymore because
they're in such a a push to process
quick and release quick they're not
being able to do that which is again
causing another National Security fa of
who these people really are and why
they're here yeah and Tom you know this
is an example of what's breaking their
Spirits I want to show you a picture I
posted on social media yesterday this is
from Eagle Pass a few days ago this is a
migrant this is a gotway the cameras
that the board Patrol have at their
remote headquarters areas where they set
up they can see things they had no agent
to respond to this guy in broad daylight
walking across the border about 15 to 20
mi north of that Port of Entry where we
see the thousands upon thousands
arriving they literally saw a guy
carrying a rifle and they could not send
anyone to apprehend them because they
had nobody Tom this is not the job that
the boorder of patol agents signed up
for and it's really just a snapshot of
how bad it is but yet secretary myor
says he's going to Mexico to try and fix
things is he going to be able to do
anything the the the Mexican immigration
folks I&M are broke they're out of
money well look La just this week I know
of four different sectors four sectors
on the Southwest border where there
wasn't a single board Patrol agent on
patrol not one we're talking about
hundreds of miles of border with no
Patrol because you're all processing and
and you and going to Mexico have another
meeting it's just
it it you don't need any more meetings
Mexico want to help us Mexico made $61
billion last year in maintenance
payments from illegal Al sending money
back to Mexico that's a big part of the
GDP they don't want to fix it plus
you're making billions of dollars
because you you got law enforcement are
corrupt a lot of the military's corrupt
a lot of the government's corrupt
they're making a mint on this whole
thing and they're being paid off by the
cartels they don't need another meeting
what they need to do is put the
remaining Mexico program back in today
they can do it the highest courts land
said it was legal and it was a game
changer of trump Administration if they
want to secure the Border like they say
put the remain of Mexico program back in
tomorrow that would that would make a
big difference to securing this border
Tom you talk about meetings speaker Mike
Johnson House speaker Mike Johnson is
apparently going to go here in early
January I believe on January 3rd down to
Eagle Pass to hold uh a press conference
to do some sort of something is this
going to do
anything you know I'm I'm I'm sick and
tired of the of dog and pony shows right
I'm sick of all of them look stay in DC
and do your job you midterms were run on
impeaching my orc I've been calling my
orch impeachment for two damn years if
they can impeach president Trump for
making a phone call they can certainly
impeach my orcus for causing the biggest
National Security crisis I've seen in
this nation since 9/11 stay in DC and do
your job impeach the secretary that
needs to be done you made the promise to
get it done get having another dog and
pony show on the border doesn't doesn't
mean squat we all know what's happening
on a border they all know what's
happening on a border stay in DC and
fight for the Safety and Security of
this nation take some action secure the
Border impeach secetary my orcas that's
what you should be doing and lastly T
just before we run out of time I
released information this week uh CBP
sources telling me there was
386,000
notices to appear so they released
386,000 out of 698,000 apprehension so
that's more than half and meanwhile you
got almost 880,000 getaways but could
another Administration could you if you
came back in can anybody house these
people or do we just have to let them
all go because they're such high
numbers well that's why you end to catch
you Rel leas that's why you put the
remain of Mexico program because you
don't have these numbers but William L
janess had a great story this week I
don't know if you've seen it grip and I
worked them on it there are thousands of
empty ice beds right now already paid
for there is a facil in California 2,000
bed for facility they got six people
there so they got nearly 2,000 empty
beds already paid for by the taxpayers
where they're going to sit empty while
they release people and put them in New
York City hotel 500 bucks a night this
isn't mismanagement I I've said it a
thousand times this is by Design if you
don't detain them they know that most
will get order removal because they
don't qualify for Asylum but they're not
in detention they'll never leave and
they'll just wait around for the next
amsy the next giveaway program this is
what this nation does over and over
again and catching release they can do
that again today they got thousands of
empty beds already paid for by the
taxpayers and they need to fill them Tom
hman thank you for taking time have a
merry Christmas as we think about those
board Patrol agents that'll be working
around the clock giving up time with
their families to try and do what they
can in a situation that is clearly
surging out of control Tom hman thank
you hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now